[Music]
I look good yes water that came from
your thigh gap no thank you
thanks for calling it again celebrity
chef Sasha trek and her fiance it
Brandon Choi what a great cause huh
you're opening a new restaurant and I
need you in the San Francisco
[Applause]
Hey hi Marcus yeah hi Sasha
hi hello hi long time yes yes very long
time was it salsa Tristan Angela Carone
Asian Oprah how much money do you have
now it's serious I'm surprised you two
lost touch he used to be so close so
when's the big wedding day he wants to
travel a bit before we settle down it's
really for the both of us I finally
realized that I don't want to marry you
I can tell you're a little bit okay
malaria and [ __ ] yourself to get you
shitty piece of [ __ ] you are scaring
I just have to start dating again there
anything worse you and Marcus are so
cute
remind me why you never got together
there's way too much history there you
still have the Corolla what are you
looking at my back seat because we had
sex back there oh my god what do you
think that it might be even smaller and
grosser than I remember yeah you better
still be talking about my back seat
[Music]
they don't want to wonder what is
how do you feel so that's news so do I
thank mines big - okay look that's
that's so great we have the most insane
freaky ass sex I can't even talk about
it otherwise I was talking about
there he is hi baby I missed your
thought was your pen scratching I missed
your taste
[Music]